[Music]
in graffiti call news submitted by
wrestling is real it all real wheel with
a W wheel a woman was charged after
covering her town in graffiti in an
attempt to contact her baby that's real
love funny baby daddy come home that's a
real strong calling Claus was it was a
paper was it like he's not worth it says
I shouldn't have to do all that but
maybe it's not about that it's more like
give me the money baby yeah my baby
needs to be taken care of
take him Nicole this is a hood call so
this helped this happened in Australia
oh this 36 year-old woman was charged
with criminal damage willful willful
damage among other things and so she
covered like public spaces with the
message Chris you Chris you need to talk
to me before baby is born or don't
bother after well that's a lot to write
with graffiti yeah oh my god no wonder
he left it's the exact same message Wow
did you just go to all of his favorite
spots I know he's having a barbeque when
you're blocked from all of his social
media i likey she underlined don't
bother bother after she's like this is
your last chance
wait this is your is that the woman's
bathroom too funny what have you just
chose the latter what if he was like
okay I just won't bother you after her I
mean I really wanna know so that's the
frustrating thing about the story that I
don't know if Chris ever called far away
she isn't her pregnancy or how far in
she is pushy named the baby would she
look pregnant out there with a spray
paint
maybe she has a mass ID on I mean he
takes care of it she's like doing it on
a park floor like the ground of a park
next to a sink like by a barbecue thing
like that like it's not even that Chris
yeah because these graffiti pieces were
popping up at different intervals of
time so like there so then that's when
people started posting online like well
it looks like you still haven't called
her Chris oh so they call her though
yeah they did she should just claim our
installation oh it's a talking piece
about our society and how social media
has run our lives you know and broken
homes yeah it's a PSA yeah you know
where she [ __ ] up she just had to
write these letters and put it in a
kangaroo's pouch and then have them all
go look for him yeah get his underwear
and let the kangaroo smell it and be
like go pee girls do that yeah and
they'll just look funny I wish they did
become acute they actually funny yeah
they they beat people yeah you could go
over there are you Chris New York police
man's in the pouch yeah so the community
know noticed board notice board posted
on their Facebook said Chris can you
please just call her before she destroys
a whole city
yeah don't forget you see jefita you can
report it to cancel the snaps and solve
how okay so she desperately needs him
back in her life right is this a night
after the babies boy is that a threat
though is it so I think she's that but
she's threatening but I still oh yeah
yeah that's okay I mean that's like a
threat like and don't bother but what it
really means is like
please but she's still trying to stand
her ground
you know just 36 girl we know a lot of
people that are old enough to know
better
[Laughter]
I'll talk to you to us thanks for
knowing my birthday though yeah you got
some 36 thank you that's amazing
wait like in what way young mentally
okay physically he'll be so funny she's
like you're way too stupid to be 36
where's the wisdom at I don't know I say
we think about like I mean if you're
really that desperate to send a message
like what else can could she have done
to not need to like graffiti up the
entire city literally pick her up or
everything else literally everything
else but then I'm thinking like what if
he does go stood where she doesn't know
the family she just deals with it right
like this should never be an option but
then I was even thinking like dude
there's flowers she doesn't sound this
money to if you really need to do it
this way you know that feeling of
desperately wanting someone back in your
life though yes yes no because I think
that's what this person is going through
yeah it's like I want to go through this
pregnancy alone I need you back in my
life and that's where it's rough yeah
yeah that's rugby just being pregnant
and like being with him was already
rough not because of him not because of
you but just being pregnant and not
knowing what the [ __ ] is going yeah
imagine doing that alone yeah yeah she
must make pretty traumatized
cuz I mean all guys want to run away
when when they're girls oh you know they
all want to run away but like they stay
though they say this I did this I'm like
baby you gotta tell you something and
then I just [ __ ] held on to his ass
yeah and I was like we're gonna have a
baby and then yeah
No he gives up and we're like there
still a chance go go go and then it's
like oh no chill saw doors yeah but when
I got my cars off four flat tires oh my
god dammit that's how you keep your man
he runs into it that dog challenge and
she was smarter she should have put like
a missing person like oh we haven't seen
and there's a cash reward and then when
they find him like I'm so sorry there's
no cash reward but listen this is the T
and they're gonna be like oh you know
pregnant moms aren't that smart because
the baby's taking all the brains you
didn't yet why do you gotta finish this
she just looked at me like I'm dead
she's like you're [ __ ] dead you know
what the real sad story is is her
graffiti skills are horrible money that
she's like - I did no way she would
tweet there's only so many characters I
guess you know yeah she's just like with
the B and a for do you guys not a coffee
pastas
yeah what is that it's where they
copy/paste things right okay especially
um like in the online meaning gaming
world especially like things like 4chan
boards where she's like you please but
like twitch chats basically like if
someone writes something and it's just
like either really funny or so stupid
that it's kind of funny other people
start copying it and sending it again so
your whole chat is just filled with like
this one guy's like actually intentional
message but it's so dumb everybody
copied it to make fun of it
just gotta whatever my stuff because
they kind of read like a copy for no
yeah and then like imagine people sort
of copying it and maybe started writing
like in random cities
funny that's a Google do online they
should send that to all the guys that
ran from their girls did you just send
them yeah pretty good same template yep
doctor break n yeah what's the name of
the font you need to mama baby ba ba ba
that's good yeah where you at child
support font with you yeah where you at
I think it's kind of a sad story man I
know either you know they fix things or
you know she got some shop support
whatever um the baby comes out graffiti
and he's like dad you need to talk the
real story is how bad was she that we'd
the guy had to run away what if that is
real what makes you assume it's her
fault mine was also thinking like dude
if you need like if you left her like
ego sitter after having this baby and so
we're like finding out that she's
pregnant then I'm like maybe you're
better off just wait yeah yeah is you
make a great point she really is you see
all we need to when you're still in love
yeah sure she's blinded by rationally
but she's strong cuz she raised a kid by
herself so maybe she could buy a father
gigolo type or gigolo to play a dad
oh that's what a ours are good for oh
hey my dad's yo that's gonna create a
whole new wave of mental issues having a
robot as a dad you see mother on methane
yeah that's a great holiday that's a
great example of a motherly a I figure I
would have loved me
I mean she's not very affectionate but
she's a pretty mother she did a great
job just be affectionate she voice yeah
the show yeah well I knew of it buddy
watch it Wow and she talked like a robot
what and no one knew she was a robot
yeah it's so true I need to go to school
now okay Vicki look good
she picks up the couch she starts
vacuuming you have the scrunchie i like
maytee I do want I would do wants to go
back you want to go back to a time of
crack sure where the 80s ago in Kerala
we know lots of crime in the 90s is
where I want to go there's a crack
cocaine like cocaine cocaine 70s
good good good good and then they ran
out of money and then turned into crack
into 80s do you guys have a quick way of
remembering the difference between crack
and cocaine
I never yeah so cocaine is the powder
form and crack is the rock form you know
the old you have you know like a tidbit
to remember what wait wait it's just
whatever people talk about it I don't
know what
cocaine is and then clearly not
crackheads which will folk rock state
crowd right so rocks they crack so crack
rock that's the rock form cocaine think
about sugar cane sugar powder okay okay
but nothing beats doing both do you
remember what it is then you know the
difference yeah cuz I never did coke
stay away from that I would recommend
those things for anyone because it's too
good you are we sell crack to the kid I
don't I'm trying to tell them okay
there's
don't do them because it's too good
don't
there's no swipe up link it's just
hashtag added don't do it cuz it's so
good you'll never want to do anything
else ever again and then you keep doing
it over and over and over this is so
[ __ ] amazing
[Music]